nos travaux cette fois-ci nous sommes
dans le
cadre de la mission que nous
d'information sur les émeutes qui sont
intervenus qui se sont déroulé le 27
juin dernier nous arrivons un peu au
terme des travaux qui sont qui sont les
nôtres je rappelle peut-être pour nos
invités d'abord je les prie de bien
vouloir nous excuser pour le l'immense
retard que nous avons pour débuter cette
audition mais lié à une activité assez
dense de la commission des lois ce matin
euh nous avons mis en place cette
mission avec l'objectif qui est de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé à
l'occasion de ces émeutes ne pas
seulement avoir un regard qui soit un
regard qui relève de la compétence
directe de la commission des lois à
savoir justice police mais d'aller
beaucoup plus loin dans ce travail et
singulièrement d'avoir aussi un peu un
regard sociologique finalement euh dès
lors que nous avons auditionné de fait
nous avons auditionné des professeurs
d'université
sociologues beaucoup de une grande
diversité de de personnalités nous
sommes allés en déplacement et pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière je regarde
madame Nara CIN puisque nous étions
ensemble à Laval qui est une commune qui
a eu un certain nombre de de
d'événements importants aussi pas que il
y en a d'autres bien évidemment on a
auditionné des maires on a auditionné
beaucoup de monde et l'idée d'ailleurs
de vous entendre c'est vous avez
évidemment réaliser
euh des films sur avec en portant un
regard sur les banlieu notamment et
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de croiser les
regards
euh de façon parce que les choses sont
assez claires pour compreniez bien nous
voulons essayer de nous approcher le
plus possible de la vérité de ce qui
s'est passé des raisons qui ont été
celles qui ont euh final ser c'est pas
le terme mais qui ont occasionné les
événements du mois de juin dernier on
aura peut-être une réponse législative
pour parti peut-être pas peut-être une
réponse réglementaire simplement
peut-être des travaux à prolonger sur
d'autres pistes mais via peut-être
d'autres commissions et c'est ça qui
nous intéresse notre rapport sera rendu
au mois de mars et nos travaux se Contin
continuent au cours du mois de février
voilà j'ai été beaucoup trop long donc
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ce matin deux autres
personnalités devaient venir mais euh al
j'ose pas dire qu'on a pas de nouvelles
mais c'est un peu ça quand même mais
vous êtes là donc c'est l'essentiel on
va vous laisser la parole les les
collègues poseront sans doute des
questions ensuite je vous indique que
normalement nous sommes retransmis en
direct sur la chaîne Public Sénat et
peut-être même le site internet du Sénat
contenu du retard je mesure pas les les
enjeux techniques mais en tous les cas
vous avez la parole alors je sais pas si
vous avez prévu un ordre entre vous deux
ou pas du tout je vais laisser la parole
à mon
alors Monsieur dufreine Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE
bonjour Merci le le cadet donc il laisse
la parole à
l'ené merci mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le Président merci de de nous
accueillir je suis un petit peu dans
l'expectative mais j'avoue une belle
expectative je trouve ça formidable
réellement que le Sénat aille sonder les
réalisateurs la culture pour parler de
la commission des lois surtout et la et
et en plus la plus belle des commissions
hein la
plus ouais mais je suis déjà venu mais
non mais enfin bon la plus importante
enfin bon on va faire voilà on a compris
eu je je je voudrais vous dire d'où d'où
je parle il se trouve que en 2007
j'avais réalisé mon premier documentaire
qui s'appelait quand la France sans bras
qui faisait suite aux émeutes de 2005 et
euh au CPE de 2006 c'était un premier
travail sur le maintien de l'ordre et
depuis cette date euh entre autres
choses je travaille beaucoup sur le
maintien de
l'ordre et notamment le le maintien de
l'ordre dit répressif puisque il y a le
maintien de l'ordre récréatif le
maintien fait de la musique le maintien
de l'ordre sportif les les les matchs et
cetera et le maintien de l'ordre
répressif et cetera et c'est peut-être
de ceela dont je pourrais éventuellement
vous parler ça compte pour moi j'ai vécu
aussi cette années à Saint-Denis et donc
j'ai une vision outre périphérique des
choses qui me semblent extrêmement
importantes euh alors puisque euh tu as
parlé de que j'étais ton aîné je
voudrais juste mettre les choses en
place par rapport à à un rapport qui
date de 2005 mais qui à mon avis aurait
pu être écrit en 2023 par la Direction
centrale des renseignements généraux ce
sera pas long mais ça me semble
capital la France a connu une forme
d'insurrection non organisée avec
l'émergence dans le temps et l'espace
d'une révolte populaire des cités sans
leader et sans proposition de programme
c'est la direction centrale des
renseignements généraux la DCRG qui
n'existe plus on pourra peut-être en
parler qui a publié ce rapport le 23
novembre 2005 les policiers y affirmé
aucune manipulation n'a été décelée
permettant d'accréditer la thèse d'un
soulèvement généralisé et organisé ainsi
les islamistes n'auraient joué aucun
rôle dans le déclenchement des violences
et dans leur expansion ils auraient au
contraire eu ouvre les guillemet tout
intérêt à un retour rapide au calme pour
éviter les amalgames les policiers
assurent par ailleurs que ouvrez les
guillemets c'est le rapport des
renseignements généraux c'est c'est pas
vous avez compris voyez d'où ça vient
les jeunes des cités étaient habités
d'un fort sentiment identitaire ne
reposant pas uniquement sur leur origine
ethnique ou géographique mais sur leur
conditions sociales d'exclus de la
société française les policiers
précisent les jeunes des quartiers sensi
se sentent pénalisés par leur pauvreté
la couleur de leur peau et leur nom ceux
qui ont saccagé les cités avaient en
commun l'absence de perspective et
d'investissement par le travail dans la
société française la conclusion les
policiers évoquaient en 2005 avec
inquiétude à propos des cités ouvrait
les guillemets des getteaux urbains à
caractère ethnique il est à craindre
désormais que tout nouvel incident
Fortui décès d'un jeune provoque une
nouvelle flambée de violence généralisée
c'était donc en 2005 tout était dit il
se trouve que Nicolas Sarkozi va
dissoudre les renseignements généraux
pour les mettre dans ce qu'on appelait
la la la dessérie qui va devenir la DGSI
euh je sais vous avez j'ai déjà
travaillé sur la la question du du du
renseignement c'est peut-être pas utile
d'en parler ici mais il est quand même
absolument incroyable de se dire qu'à 20
ans d'écart quasiment 18 ans d'écart
tout était déjà dit l'élément
déclencheur est toujours le même la mort
d'un pardon je suis d'accord vous êtes
d'accord non mais je vous dirai après
vas-y ah oui d'accord euh si vous êtes
d'accord c'est c'est c'est c'est parfait
euh donc il y a toujours un élément
déclencheur dès lors qu'on parle
d'émeutes
il est intéressant de voir que les
renseignements généraux parlaient de
soulèvement populaire des quartiers il
est intéressant de voir que les les
acteurs des quartiers pour 2023 parle de
révolte parle de soulèvement et ne parle
ou de colère et ne parle pas d'émeutes
dès lors que l'on parle d'émeutes comme
vous l'avez fait au début qui est le
langage courant en fait qu'est-ce que
l'on fait on pointe uniquement le côté
délictuel et criminel l'émeut et on
dévitalise totalement le message qu'il y
a derrière il s'agit pas de dire est-ce
qu'on est pour ou contre le message mais
je vous remercie de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse écouter qu'il y a des messages
qui sont autre que ce que la doxa
politico-médiatique grosso modo nous a
raconté en 2023 comme en
2005 alors
Monsieur Paron coup là voilà euh bonjour
à toutes et à tous je tiens à remercier
remercier la commission des lois pour
l'organisation de cette commission le
président et toutes les personnes
présentes au sein de cette Assemblée je
salue mon confrère David jufreen pour
ses travaux lui ainsi que mes aînés je
suis très respectueux vous voyez de ceux
qui étaient là avant moi pour leurs
travaux en ce qui concerne la question
des violences policières parce que j'ai
réussi à comment dire à comprendre qu'en
fait c'était un fléo qui minait la
société française depuis bien longtemps
bien avant ma naissance donc je vais
faire un retour rapide sur mon parcours
je m'appelle jariki je suis cinéaste je
viens de la ville de grgny que vous
connaissez peut-être ville
malheureusement comment dire la plus
pauvre de France est connue un peu pour
son côté sulfureux donc voilà j'ai
grandi
là-bas dans le quartier de la Grande
Borne et malheureusement le quartier de
la grandeborne et d'autres quartiers on
va dire on fait face à la police plus
que la norme si je peux dire ça comme ça
ça et malheureusement les rapports sont
souvent conflictuels
euh il y a de la peur il y a de la
défiance et euh ça je l'ai vu
depuis l'âge de 10 ans je vais vous
raconter une anecdote un de mes aînés
que j'apprécié beaucoup
euh s'est fait contrôler devant mes yeux
alors que je sortais de l'école avec mes
amis j'avais 10 ans et euh voilà il
était en train de faire la mécanique sur
sa voiture et une patrouille de ce est
arrivé et très vite c'est monté voilà ce
qu'on a pu voir avec George Floyd euh le
le le genou sur la sur la tête les
injures le tutoement euh
délibéré ça j'ai vu ça que soit moi ou
d'autres personnes on a vu ça très très
tôt donc c'est très très difficile de
grandir et de se construire avec voilà
c'est ce genre de de situation car il y
a directement sentiment de de de
défiance et de peur qui se met en place
bref je vais m'arrêter de ce côté-là
mais j'ai grandi j'ai développé des
passions notamment pour cinéma et en
2015 j'ai réussi à intégrer la féis qui
est la meilleure école de cinéma de de
France voilà j'ai réalisé un premier
court-métrage qui voilà dieu merci a eu
un petit écho et par la suite je me suis
dit j'aimerais bien faire un un
court-métrage qui serait un peu plus
ambitieux qui serait un peu plus
d'utilité publique sans prétenion aucune
et voilà je je me suis tourné vers mes
amis vers ma vie et vers ce qui se
passait malheureusement actuellement en
France donc on était en plein dans
l'affaire Adama trauré Théo laka donc je
me suis dit
bon nous aussi à grgny malheureusement
des fois il y a ce genre de choses qui
se
passe dans cette ville donc je vais
faire un film en tout cas en
courtmétrage euh sur les violences
policières et je dis bien violence
policière et non bavure policière parce
que bavure policière on aue qu'il y a
une erreur c'est fait une fois deux fois
mais quand c'est constant c'est
systémique voire systématique ça ça
s'appelle des violences des crimes
policiers donc je tiens vraiment à à
bien préciser euh les termes sont
importants quand on les utilise donc je
me suis dit que j'allais faire un film
dessus voilà en fin 2017 et voilà il y a
eu un un petit écho quand même on a été
pris à Cannes et on a eu quelques prix
en festival et cetera bref
euh ce que je veux dire par tout ça
c'est que si on veut comprendre la
question euh des des violences
policières attention c'est pas il y a un
camp les des gentils et un camp des
méchants d'accord euh c'est pas c'est
pas une diichotomie euh il y a du mal
des deux côtés il y a de la délinquence
euh dans les quartiers ça il faut le
dire on va pas faire le le bisou zours
mais euh ce que moi et d'autres
personnes amoureuses de justice et de
paix tout simplement parce que beaucoup
de personnes veulent vivre en paix en
France et ça peut étonner certains et
certaines mais bien évidemment en
banlieu beaucoup de personnes veulent
vivre en paix et comment on peut y
arriver et ben tout simplement en en
respectant ces personnes en les
humanisant euh en quand un policier par
exemple je vais vous parler de Steve
Maya
caniko voilà qui est décédé euh en 2019
lors de la fête de la musique suite à à
une intervention de police le policier
voilà qui a été mis en cause euh va être
promu chef de la circonscription de
police nationale à Lyon quelques jours
avant qu'il passe en procès euh pareil
une ou deux semaines avant Tho luaka à
bobini voilà qui a été violé je dis bien
violé parce que quand on introduit un
objet
euh forcé
euh en quelqu'un ça s'appelle un viol
donc quand à la suite de son procès
enfin de du jugement des policiers bah
qui l'ont agressé euh en émane du surcis
ce genre de choses font que
malheureusement la la défiance va être
automatique et on peut pas tout de suite
dans les médias avoir confiance on va
pas essentialiser tout le corps policier
bien évidemment moi le premier je suis
tombé sur des policiers qui faisaient
leur métier par vertu par amour et par
souci de de de servir la la population
française quel que soit son origine mais
c'est ces petits excusez-moi du terme
cracha aux familles de victimes et à la
population française tout simplement
font que il y a une défiance qui se met
en place et et la synergie elle peut pas
être totale quoi donc j'ai essayé avec
mon court-métrage en en m'inspirant bien
évidemment des travaux de mes aînés
l'algée Mathieu cassovit et cetera de de
proposer le pourquoi du comment parfois
dans les banlieu ça peut être
incandescent entre l'institution
policière et et les gens de bleu voilà
merci à
vous merci Monsieur alors il y a-t-il
des questions moi j'en ai quelquesunes
mais allez-y alors madame narassig
oui merci beaucoup pour C ces propos
introductifs ce qui nous laisse je pense
du temps pour un pour un échange plus
plus précis sur ce qui s'est passé en en
2023 et et par rapport justement à à
2005 puis que vous avez commencé
monsieur du par parler de de 2005 où en
2005 il y avait c'était quand même plus
circonscrit sur la les émeutes il y
avait eu moins de de contagion au niveau
national et par ailleurs le lien direct
avec les événements
euh déclencheur la la la mort des deux
jeunes euh à à clichi était était établi
et contesté par personne et ce que on
entend quand même beaucoup euh depuis le
début de nos auditions et dans nos
déplacements c'est et notamment à
travers aussi les témoignages de ceux
qui ont sont passés en comparution
immédiate c'est que Naël enfin le
l'événement de déclencheur la mort de
Naël est très peu cité est cité plus sur
les par les émetiers en en région
parisienne en île-de-fance mais beaucoup
moins ailleurs et puis il y a quand même
eu une diffusion là qui est quand
même on connaît le rôle des réseaux
sociaux notamment qui qui euh qui a été
beaucoup plus large et inattendu euh et
y compris dans des dans des euh sur des
territoires où on n' pas l'habitude de
voir des émeutes euh au niveau national
euh et donc je je voudrais comprendre de
votre point de vue un peu cette
déconnexion parce qu'on entend aussi on
a aussi vu des médiateurs et CEA et qui
donc disent même s'il y a pas de des
sociologues qui disent que même s'il y a
pas eu euh de de revendication politique
constru par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
sur elle il y a quand même un clair
phénomène d'identification et il y a on
va dire une atmosphère et et une colère
qui existe et qui peut expliquer aussi
cet embrasement même si elle n'est pas
clairement exprimé euh et et donc d'une
part plus généralement à à à vous deux
comment est-ce que vous voyez cette
cette déconnexion qu'il y a avec aussi
c'est vrai il y a eu beaucoup de
comportements qu'on peut qualifier
d'opportuniste euh avec des pillages
très organisés qui étaient clairement
pas juste parce que on mange pas à sa
fin à cause du à cause de l'inflation he
et de de réduction du pouvoir d'achat
mais qui était aussi une volonté de per
des choses qu'on va pouvoir revendre
avec avec clairement aussi des lien avec
du crime organisé quand même enfin des
bandes et Cera donc l'arêvage de mortier
qui était aussi très organisé tout ça
donc il y a quand même un des phénomènes
un peu complexes
peut-être qui qui sont qui sont mis en
place de manière un peu plus enfin qu'on
a pas vu en 2005 euh et et je voudrais
comprendre de votre point de vue sur ces
origines sociales
euh comment est-ce que vous expliquez
qu'elle soit pas exprimée clairement
mais quel queles sont quel
quel quelles sont pour vous leur
importance et et et et les mécanismes
qu'il y a derrière ça et et aussi le
fait qu'on soit on soit passé dans un
niveau de violence qui est en fait plus
élevé avec une volonté vraiment délibéré
là de cibler les policiers de cibler
aussi dans pas mal d'endroits les
bâtiments publics et aussi même souvent
des des des endroits qui profitent à la
population
de manière beaucoup plus systématique
euh et euh et puis monsieur dufren comme
vous avez aussi travaillé sur les
question de de maintien de l'ordre je
voudais avoir un petit peu votre votre
avis sur
euh sur sur C cette façon qu'on a
peut-être un peu spécifique française de
de gérer le maintien de l'ordre est-ce
que ça est-ce que ça augmente le
désordre finalement euh ou est-ce que
c'est est-ce que donc on doit interroger
ces pratiques de maintien de l'ordre et
euh euh et et et et pour euh pour
Monsieur Diara euh euh par rapport à
cette relation avec avec la police euh
justement quel est euh euh quel est
l'effet euh de de ce que vous appelez
effectivement des des discriminations et
des des et des comportements violents
systémiques que cette perceptionl euh à
quel qu dans le les travaux que vous
avez fait pour produire euh pour pour
réaliser vos films euh euh quel est le
vraiment euh euh le le le le niveau de
de de sentiment est-ce que c'est très
très partagé dans dans chez les jeunes
de ces quartiers ou est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui reste sur des des
populations très restreintes voilà merci
Madame josand puis madame Floren et puis
peut-être monsieur kerouche et sans
doute
moi merci monsieur le Président et et
merci à nos intervenants pour leurs
propos introductifs effectivement qui
laissent davantage la place au au au
débat mais euh euh je dans ce que ce que
vous avez dit j'ai quelques
interrogations et peut-être quelques euh
euh
rectification à faire parce que on on
est déjà sur sur une un niveau de de
débat qui semble donc laisser entendre
qu'on n'a pas pris en compte le fait
qu'il y a toujours un fait générateur
qui est la mort d'un jeune et dans le
cadre de ces de cette commission des
travaux que nous avons réalisé des
auditions que nous en fait il a
clairement été dit euh que le le point
de départ très clairement est la mort
d'un d'un jeune simplement euh comment
expliquez-vous le fait que la mort d'un
jeune puisse alors moi je suis sénatrice
des pirnises orientales puisse générer
dans certaines villes euh des émeutes et
des débordements et des manifestations
de violence euh donc important et dans
d'autres nom je m'explique plus
précisément Perpignan euh qui est une
place en général de des meuts de
violence et de de de rébellion hein
clairement pour différentes raisons que
que vous connaissez en 2005 ça a été euh
très très très fort très violent chez
nous euh on a même été malheureusement
euh cité en exemple comme étant un
centre névralgique de cette violence et
donc de ces ces difficultés social qui
qui sont souvent exprimés euh et comme
soubassement de ceses des émeutes et et
très étrangement en 2023 on a interrogé
ici des spécialistes personne n'a su
nous donner la réponse euh pourquoi en
2023 sur père Pignan ça n'a pas bougé
mais pas bougé du tout voilà quel est
votre regard là-dessus deuxième chose
dans dans dans sans trahir les les
secrets de nos auditions mais il a été
aussi clairement dit qu'il y a eu deux
temps dans ces émeutes il y a eu le
moment où on a parlé de cette mort du
jeûne systématiquement comme étant le
l'élément l'événement de référence pour
justifier euh ou ou en tout cas qui a
entraîné hein c'est peut-être pas le
terme justifieré mais les manifestations
de violence et il a été aussi clairement
dit et partagé par par beaucoup
d'observateurs de de de d'obédience et
de niveau d'analyse différents qui a eu
un deuxième temps à partir duquel euh
les euh on ne faisait plus référence à
la mort de Naël mais on faisait
référence à euh un tas de d'autres
éléments qui peuvent justifier des
manifestations de de de violence et et
et notamment effectivement des
difficultés sociales mais pas que euh
donc ça c'est une c'est la rectification
que je voulais faire parce que c'est
important aussi on a du mal à comprendre
ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné on
oublie quasiment la mort du jeune pour
justifier euh les les émeutes ou en tout
cas se sentir en adéquation avec un
mouvement de de de
violence là où je voudrais avoir votre
avis c'est vous êtes des professionnels
de
l'image ce qui a été clairement dit
aussi dans le cadre de ces auditions
c'est que le le deuxième notamment
moment pardon a été notamment abondé par
le fait que il y avait un culte une
course à à à à à l'image à aux images
choc et et l'influence des réseaux
sociaux a été pointé du doigt comme
étant un élément déterminant puisque les
jeunes faisaient la course à ceux qui
auraient le l'image la plus la plus
forte qui passerait bon non seulement en
boucle sur les les les réseaux de de
communication et les et les et et les
les les groupes euh privés mais aussi et
surtout celui qui pourrait avoir son
image sur les les chaînes d'information
et quel est pour vous qu'est-ce qui
justifie donc le rapport à l'image
évidemment on se dit c'est une notoriété
peut-être rechercher même même de courte
durée mais une notoriété quand même mais
mais pourquoi pourquoi chercher cette ce
ces images choc plutôt que d'être plutôt
témoin par exemple de ce que vous vivez
et et et et de reprendre les propos tels
que vous les exprimez c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus justes par
rapport à ce que vous vivez et
finalement euh quelle est votre analyse
par rapport au fait que ces images
choquent et cette cette violence peut
être contreproductive par rapport au
messages que que que souhaitent
justement transmettre ceux qui qui sont
en en situation peut-être pas donc
d'meutes je j'entends ce que vous dites
mais de de de de rébellion ou de
manifestation d'une d'une colère voilà
merci merci Madame Floren merci monsieur
le Président euh merci beaucoup monsieur
dufen et Monsieur Diara pour
vosos vos premières interventions euh
évidemment c'est m'intéresse
particulièrement je suis sénatrice des
hautes scèes
j'étais député
euh donc de la 4e circonscription des
hautes scènes jusqu'en 2022 qui comprend
la ville de Nant
et je suis toujours élu à Suren et euh
et donc particulièrement intéressé et je
vais pas répendre ce qu' dit mais ma
collègue mais effectivement sur le fait
générateur euh comment vous dire
euh